tout le monde sait squeeze et rien du
tout aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur vos
armes savais tu fais mika autant vous
prévenir maintenant on a eu au moins 600
fou rire durant cette vidéo j'espère
vraiment que ça va vous plaire et puis
moi je retourne manger mes chocolats
n'ont pu ainsi pendant le quai et voilà
et voilà et y'a pas le rocket jump dans
ce jour là j'ai pas vu le mur je dis
mais qu'est ce qu'ils bossent gagnant ya
rien pour sortir à paris
il ouvrait la sévère de taille était
élevé qu il a fait à merde je trouvais
touche veulent appuyer sur entrée j'en
ai marre j'en ai un dans mon gars je
suis en mondial à worms quoi parce qu'il
semble que tu as l'air tu as fait un
truc qui ressemblait à ça mais pourquoi
ça passe au-dessus maquis taux plus
élevés mouche à pau bc bima elle est où
ton frugeois à seller j en bas de la map
fait du bruit
lars boom
on va faire une petite heure un petit
scanner défenseur non mes mecs quoi
c'est gênant quoi le grand splash quoi à
la rampe elle était là pour lui quoi non
parce qu'on ne touche pas pour les riz
qu il est sacré je sais que tu as la
chance avec qui tu veux que je fasse à
part à part ça ouais owendo
ah ah oui bah oui bah voilà hum hum
jovet mal grenade là pour qui rebondit
sur le truc et qu'elle aille pin entre
sur toi allez vas-y merde t'es trompé de
touche a les jambes et à la bonne heure
c'était beau donc la mine la mine est un
grand vide comme ça mais tu inverse et
voilà talleu des le dégage de worms est
quand même extrêmement viril quoi ça va
mal à la tête
oh mon gars tu as pris trop cher oh oh
bah oui on va la méga qu'on joue quoi
parce qu'en fait le saut dans une
piscine c'est super nous alors j'ai
voulu tester le saut dans le fût la
gueule
[Applaudissements]
et pour avoir un peu de compagnie selon
moi un mouton dans le jeu halo halo
houston j'entends j'entends un
tremblement de terre info j'ai un
chalumeau ça fait quoi ça permet de
perforer le seul mot c'est pour creuser
le sol on n'aura pas la banane mika pas
la banane au tu vas y petit bug est ce
que ça te fait rire non
ok est ce que les warm sont bien placés
pour une fois bordel chez les jaunes
mais vas-y mais non mais voilà mettais
ma à bas les couilles
bonsoir comment ça là bas il faut plutôt
bien j'ai la forme là ça me fait plaisir
là nontron pages avaient tous anticipé
veille
je suis pas mou le mec je voulais que ça
lui prend les cheveux tu vois pour sa
superbe
superbe bon les mecs je vais faire un
truc de gros chiens alors je m'en bats
les couilles
[ __ ] j'ai géré mon gars des bons gars
et c'est pour faire style des effets
spéciaux de dungy tous n'ont pas foulé
ricotta pas droit la turbulente a vu
squeeze carottes mec attentes a appris
que des gars ouais mais c'est une blague
bon gars mais c'est une blague
riou perçu au regard de ma tête de
crapauds et s'accrocher pas que le vieux
résident à l'aller c'est vrai pour tom
cruise pour 10 go à j'aime pas les
quatre juges aiment pas les casques que
ya une carte de temps et tient bon ami
alors alors rp z attend tom cruise
j'arrive attends attends pas brad pitt
arrête ces bons soit calme attends tu
vas faire quoi là la position penchée
genre mais comment pour revenir au haut
au monde qu'un entre les deux yeux ça
lui est prête à pas utile étant à eau
comme ça tu me fais la bise huîtres de
l'unctad and sons juifs on s'appelle la
chanson tueur club
quand tu te fais la gueule normal quoi
le mais qui se transforme carrément en
ouvriers dans le jeu et votre problème
oh là là ils attaquent d'entrée aulas a
c'était bon ça c'est dur ce passage que
fut t'es pas d'accord
oh la la c'est normal c'est ce passé
j'ai 38 ans avec patrick ou humaine
bonsoir salut comment ça se fait bon
c'est un peu de la merde ce mode
la phrase orageux la face du café des
derniers dix fois de suite le super mon
tour au palais
la société pas tu vas bien soit alors le
groupe points ex aequo fruchart d'abord
parce qu'il ya des gens plus gros barbe
en savoie la partie
[Musique]